20 years separating these two but that's
what we love about chess david age is
just a number exactly and hare krishna
he might be one of the oldest players in
this tournament but he is
very experienced and still many good
years ahead for him meanwhile the game
has started and i'm personally very
happy
it's one of my favorite openings i know
the see-through sicilian the alapin
variation of the sicilian and uh it's
one you rarely see at top level these
days right it it was rare and i was
going to ask you
who launched the first surprise because
uh
you know we did hear ramesh the coach of
pragnanda saying hey there's going to be
a few surprises in store for harry
krishna but then harry krishna opened up
with
your childhood favorites and i also know
that you still use it as a regular i
still do uh mostly in blitz chess these
days i very rarely play this in
classical chess this opening which does
have a reputation maybe of not being the
most critical way of fighting against
the sicilian defense
white occupies the center with pawns
actually as we see here we catch up to
the game white does have two very strong
pawns in the center but the reason it's
not so popular these days is because
black is easily able to undermine
white's center also a lot of forcing
variations in this opening it's been
worked out very deeply in certain
variations and
it surprises me that harry krishna spent
a bit of time there because black
had challenged his center white didn't
have too many moves in the end white
bishop coming out and now after this
trade of pawns in the center which is
very common uh i'm expecting harry
krishna to take back himself black has
some options there so pragmata
i would say he was maybe slightly
surprised but
working with someone like ramesh working
with other indian players
uh pregnant he's had many great uh
kind of sparring partners he for sure
has studied this before the see-through
sicilian it's rare at the top level but
he's a younger player prague and at the
younger levels this opening's still very
very common and their black defense and
solidifies his knight in the centre of
the board with his bishop
and
yeah so i'm just checking the database
mainly one move mainly white just
castles the king gets it to safety
another alternative is for the queen
to develop in front of the king i'm not
that keen on that move actually
um stick to the most natural move but
once again we see hari krishna just
slowly considering his options before he
plays the main move
one thing i have to say about harry
krishna you know normally he strikes me
as quite confident player but i do
remember on the tour last year that he
was the sole person that lost to
abi manu mishra wow yeah
yeah and
sometimes these kind of losses can have
an impact on yeah they can come and
haunt you and you'll be thinking well
you know
i lost once to a prodigy do i want to
lose to someone young again no maybe
just play it safe yeah um the
see-through sicilian although it is
maybe a safer option than open sicilians
which are more kind of double-edged more
pieces on the board see through
sicilians it's still quite hard to kind
of force the draw or play completely
safe it's the type of openings where you
have to be a bit energetic and you have
to for example now as you mentioned
ivanka you have to just castle the king
with white
maybe go on the attack using white
central pawn which is quite far advanced
using that pawn as kind of um a way to
split black's defenses to try and just
throw your pieces forward hare krishna
these days his style is maybe more
strategic positional he just wants to
kind of get a middle game
one of the best end game players in the
world uh harry krishna but
i'm surprised to see him think because
as you mentioned the most natural move
the most common move
is probably also the best one
just white's king needs to get to safety
black's king still takes a while uh but
then again the reason harry krishna has
paused for thought potentially is
because he fears prague's homework he
fears what prague has studied in the
past that's the only reason i can think
for her kind of spending two three
minutes at this point so maybe he's kind
of like been double surprised so he
launched the first surprise but
pragnando was like ah i'm not bothered i
know my stuff and so now it's harry
krishna's turn to just to kind of try to
consider his options does he play the
main move does he try to do something
now a little bit creative um as far as i
know as far as i remember this move uh
this kind of idea of trading a set of
pawns in the center for black and
bringing the bishop out it's quite new
it's only become popular lately uh it's
still quite rare compared to black maybe
just occupying the center with pawns
trying to get the black king castled
i've nev i mean i've played the c3
sicilian
i mean hundreds of times in my life over
the board thousands of times in my life
on online chess and i think i've never
actually faced this one
or actually i have once but um yeah
either way harry krishna deciding to
meet a surprise with a surprise and that
is new
i mean it's quite a normal move i mean
after all it develops the the night but
nope never been played before last
studied
2012. quite a while ago these days to me
it feels like yesterday but it's
actually 10 years ago
was four years old oh no wait he wasn't
he was six
yeah i'm not that good in math
why did i think 2012 was four years ago
very strange
he doesn't feel that anyway
yeah
he's young
that's the moral of the story but either
way i think this is a clear sign hare
krishna he's freestyling uh he's out of
his book uh when we say out of book we
mean out of lines that you've studied
before and
um the reason i'm not a fan of that
white knight move if you look at white's
knight now in front of the white queen
it blocks the queen it blocks the white
dark squared
bishop it's uh not clear that that
knight actually helps or that it's
actually better than where it previously
stood so okay white now should really
castle the king
before it's too late meanwhile prague
has just pushed upon getting ready to
develop black star squad bishop out one
square the fianchetto as we call it and
then blackboard castle
so harry krishna really needs to play a
bit more energetically with his pieces
now
before prague is completely coordinated
and completely mobilized with his pieces
yeah
and uh i just also wanted to mention do
you remember how we saw the selfie our
ari was watching football and also
listening to us at the same time
well they say that the football match is
between slavia praha and dynamo i was
just lucky that they were playing while
they're there well i'm there on holiday
so yeah i hope you're enjoying the chess
and also very much the football
absolutely cool okay is i is that held
in prague then at slavia's home ground
because talking of prague hara christian
has been living in prague for a few
years as does david navarro so maybe
just sending some support there ari for
his uh his local
chess players that meanwhile a big
decision for harry krishna because he's
actually sacrificed a pawn
white has abandoned the pawn in the
center of the board instead by this
knight jump he's going after black's
light squared bishop so he's saying okay
you can take that pawn i don't really
care it's going to open up lines if you
capture it meanwhile white capturing the
black light squared bishop on the next
turn will shatter the black structure
so really interesting do you like that
one your banker because it's it does
entail some risk
risk is good
and you know what is going on they're
offensive the only thing that i'm a
little bit concerned about is having sat
next to you and actually looked at the
games of the grand masters i see that
grand masters don't like to make these
direct moves just like that they like to
prepare them for instance by developing
your pieces connecting everything so
in that sense
i don't like it
but
but my true nature says
it's going forward
i love it
yep i agree um this is the type of move
if i was playing a blitz game i would
play it just because it looks scary and
uh
actually it has scared prague into not
capturing a pawn uh practice developing
a piece there but uh yeah the other
reason i like it is because i'm obsessed
with pawn structures and now if white's
knight does capture the black light
square bishop
we surely will see that move from harry
krishna is the only justification of his
previous move um after that happens a
black structure is compromised forever
also white will have the bishop pair so
even if white ends up a pawn down there
will be compensation
yeah if i were white take the bishop
give up the pawn don't worry about that
you know focus on the bishop pair
exactly exactly yeah love it you get
some squares as well and i think we'll
show this in a moment uh because okay
let's show it now uh a really critical
moment caused by harry krishna jumping
forward with his knight trying to
capture this bishop and uh i'm slightly
surprised prague didn't capture this
pawn in the center of the board i guess
white's idea was that after a capture a
trade here and a check maybe to the
black king potentially this is awkward
black does have double pawns this is an
annoying check against his king instead
prague focusing not on materialism
instead just development instead so okay
bishop has developed a g7 and after this
trade
white now has to make a decision do you
just castle do you abandon this pawn to
its fate this pawn is doomed i think the
knight attacking it the bishop attacking
it you can't actually support it with
another pawn if you push this guy
forward it just gets captured by the
black knight therefore i think it's time
to just gambit this pawn as you
vancouver mentioned focus on the bishop
pair focus on
trying to play against black's pawn
structure and i think it's time for
white to castle the king
and uh
if white is given time for example if
black just plays a nothing move if white
is given time to somehow
it's hard to achieve but somehow
solidify these pawns then actually this
is a very common pattern black's bishop
now is locked out of the game forever
but um but i don't think white has that
luxury meanwhile though surprises keep
coming i haven't predicted a single one
of harry krishna's moves because in this
position instead of the most natural
move castling which we've been kind of
screaming for for the last five moves
he's just pinned this black knight and
look at this pawn structure that might
arise if black castles getting out of
that pin then after bishop takes knight
pawn takes look how ugly these black
pawns are isolated isolated doubled and
isolated pawns and uh yes black might
win this guy in the center of the board
but the rest is just a wreckage for
black and this is what harry krishna is
aiming for he's i mentioned strategic
player an in-game uh kind of specialist
so he's also focusing on this type of
pawn structure i'm pretty sure prague in
this position because he's quite
strategic as well i think he'll guard
this knight with a piece for example uh
bringing his queen out so now if there
is a trade he doesn't have to isolate
these two pawns he can just take back
with his queen guarding everything
now being what is it probably like 15
years younger than vishy anand or
something like that is he very
influenced by vaishyanand his style of
play harry krishna
i would say yes because all indians are
vishy is such a kind of legendary figure
in chess and harry krishna would have
grown up following his games harry
krishna he's always been quite
individual especially with his opening
choices very creative he never plays
main lines really he's always ducking
and diving and choosing ways to surprise
his opponents um i mean he's created
some chessable courses as well on maybe
some
some lines that other top grandmasters
forget like the french defense but yeah
either way he's very individual but i
think he there is some influence from
bishi
of playing with the initiative
especially and do you do you think vichy
will play in the olympiad
i think we all hope so right because
india will have two teams right uh
because the olympiad is going to be
played in chennai yeah at least two
teams i think they can actually have
more if there's an odd number of teams
in the whole event they can have an
extra team to balance out the numbers so
potentially even three yes do you think
vivienne will be tempted to play olympia
yes right ian chennai you know this is
why he played his world championship
match i think he's from chennai i'm
pretty sure yeah yeah yeah well isn't he
from madras he's from madras yeah of
course the tiger from address i can how
can i be so silly sorry my um he's been
living there for years right yeah yeah
yeah
imagine
him at the head vishy of all of the
young guns i mean all of the young
prodigies in the rest of the team yeah
so who do you imagine will be on so
let's say vichy place listen dream vishy
anand place in the olympiad who will be
on the first team then so that would be
harry krishna yeah avidit
uh adiban does aliban get in adam
probably
i would be tempted to put five yeah if i
had two teams i would be tempted to put
the young ones
so that would be pragnanda nihal siren
uh
uh arigaisi
or maybe arigaiste would be top board
and then pragananda's second board and
then yeah so put them all together so
that they can do some damage and they
could all get a nice experience and then
you know i would have like the legends
team which is like yeah
and vidic
imagine
yeah
mid-20s and we're calling him a legend
already because compared to them he's
a lot older yeah but uh yeah i mean you
could make an argument for any of these
young guys eric guys you mentioned as
well of being in the first team
they're just i mean there's such
strength and depth
in india these days
dozens and dozens of world-class players
coming through it literally seems like
every day there is a new indian grand
master i mean it's so impressive the
amount of progress
and the amount of grand masters that
india is producing it just
it just it's beyond belief because i
know that uh say for instance in the uk
you know it's been which recently had
ravi harrier but you know he was the
first one in a long time
i think we've had two or three
grandmasters in the last 10 years india
have had
probably 20 or 30 in the last three
years alone so
uh three four years alone so yeah
incredible impressive yeah when uh do
you do you guys know of course because
we're hoping you as well will play when
will teams be announced what is sort of
the deadline um i'm not sure the exact
deadline normally it's a month or two in
advance um
so this summer sometime it'll be early
summer that the teams will be announced
and often they're chosen they're picked
beforehand and then countries will have
training camps england we don't really
do this
but uh for example the indian players
they'll be training together for weeks
sort of in advance months in advance
just i mean that'll be a huge highlight
for them especially the indian players
yeah
it's it's quite funny with the olympiads
because often you have a big disparity
between the teams you know and you'll
have teams who take the event very very
seriously and just to confirm uh
pragnanda did in fact play the move that
david suggested defending the night with
the queen and some of the teams just
really prepare very very seriously you
know they have cams they have not just
one captain they have uh two captains
they also have someone at home
doing the the hard work you know
saying to the players say a sense
players this is what you're going to
play you know they the players can wake
up and they'll be like
a message in their inbox and the
analysis is there and then you have
other teams where
it's not like that yeah let's put it
kindly and it's maybe you know
five players and the captain and maybe
the captain helps them maybe the captain
doesn't help them that's a bad captain
i mean but it but it's a you know being
a captain is actually quite uh
a full-time job in fact i would even say
it's a two-person job you know you
forget that one person can do it yeah
because
if you're talking about helping the team
prepare that's already four or five
hours and then once they're actually
present watching the game
you really have to be focused there you
can't just be like
nice game over there and look at the top
boards you actually have to be sat there
watching the flow of how your players
are doing you have to be morally
supportive you also have to provide
words of wisdom after the game or maybe
just words of encouragement and also
there's a very very important situation
which is draw offers the player can ask
their team captain whether they should
accept a draw ah and this is where a
player
a team can almost
cheat i don't want to cheat or help
their player how much can the captains
they can only say no and they can only
say yes okay okay in the presence of the
arbiter yeah
no extra words can be said wow
this is where it comes into play it
depends on your tone so if i were to ask
you and say hey can i take a draw and
you were to say to me and you're a
stronger player you'll go no no
then i said i know okay get back there
because i'm winning yeah yeah i'm doing
good yeah and uh think about that a
little bit and uh if you say to me yes
then you know okay yeah absolutely yeah
this is a good decision you may be worse
and uh this can be a really really
helpful so say for instance i'm a pawn
down and you say to me you're stronger
than me and you say no absolutely get
back there and play then i know i have
enough compensation for the porn i know
that i should be feeling hopeful well
interesting twist though i kind of like
it it is a little bit of a twist but
this is where it depends on your captain
so some captains
they might go i we've even had a captain
turn around and go i don't know just do
what you like not helpful i wonder what
that situation is when magnus plays he's
played a few olympians right yeah he is
sort of a conference with his captain i
don't think he even asks the captain i
think you can just trust magnus to take
a good decision yeah i'm pretty sure
magnus doesn't need to ask a captain
but yeah it's interesting ivanka once uh
i was talking to a member of a different
team and he was saying oh yeah i'm just
off from my massage with the team
masseuse um and then i'm gonna go and
order something
specific from the team chef and i was
sitting there being like oh
great
england
[Applause]
anyway
back to the chest because queen
elizabeth give the english chess team
some money yes recognize us as a sport
that would be a nice step forward chess
is a sport and uh okay some moves on the
board so we did predict until just two
moves ago and then uh after we saw the
black queen come out trade bishop for
night uh as expected both kings have now
castled white's knight as well guarding
the white pawn in the center of the
board so
for now temporarily pregnant does have
an issue to deal with and that is the
black bishop the black bishop is locked
out of the game and also black does have
this pawn structure if you look on this
central file the e file that has doubled
pawns there so uh some two small
strategic things to worry about long
term
also the clock uh we talked to practice
coach just before this time trouble
rearing its ugly head again and uh if he
can speed up if he can get his bishop
into the game to counter and compensate
for his pawn structure then i think he's
doing well um black's knight in the
center of the board is good at least but
now okay bringing the rook into the game
that's good yeah and uh still in the
balance still could go either way this
game and you were
you were correct ivanka
chennai used to be madras
the tour director just uh messaged me so
we're on fire today our math is on point
geography
ask us anything
let's focus on the movies
yeah definitely talking about asking us
anything we do want to get excite
everyone excited about the chats
everyone is enthusiastic and so we
really appreciate it if you tweet us
tweet us your questions your thoughts
and also your selfies we love seeing
your pictures and you can do all these
things by tweeting us using the hashtag
chest champs and we will feature them on
the show because this position is wild
it's an open position and uh when the
position is open by that i mean that
there there's not too many pawns in the
middle of the board it means that every
price
of uh every price of your move
counts
because if you're inaccurate then one
person will suddenly get the initiative
the momentum will be on their side and
you can see both players are now just
jostling for putting their pieces in the
right squares
and you can tell much uh how much pride
is at stake in this game both players
super focused harry krishna wants to
show he's the more experienced of the
two he's still one of the best players
in india and uh he wants to show his
younger rival he still needs to do some
work whereas prague wants to show that
he has arrived he deserves to be in that
top team for india at the olympiad and
okay his last move there prague just
sidestepping back with the black queen
to where it came from i'm not a huge fan
of that move
but he is at least attacking a pawn on
this b file with the queen
and
maybe that's a threat maybe it's not a
threat because that white's rook could
get in the game but either way uh prague
at least he's up the pace with his last
couple of moves he's playing slightly
quicker again
and harry krishna what's he going to
come up with i think he's going to push
a pawn i'm not sure which pawn maybe
push the pawn that's attacked right now
maybe we'll see harry the each pawn at
some point getting pushed uh we could
see anything happen here but uh as
yvanka says it's a pretty much open
position right now still loads of pieces
on the board queen's on the board that's
the main thing
and a lot of life left who would you
rather be if you had to say if you had
to choose right now
i would rather be
black even though i know that
the computer prefers to be white
i would just kind of say that you know
black's position is slightly easier to
play you know the plan is a little bit
more straightforward for instance the
what the black knight in the middle can
just jump to the f4 square maybe there's
even some sacrifices rook takes night at
the right time not now and i was just
going to ask the question
black is attacking the pawn on b2 should
it be defended and harry krishna says
yes
defends it with a rook it's a bit
passive though not where he wants to put
the rook uh that white rook should be
destined for bigger things than just
sitting behind a porn defending it but
he's thinking okay he needs to stabilize
that's the number one priority and long
term white is doing well remember
because white has the better
more kind of healthy pawn structure than
black
yeah that's a passive move though i'm
not sure i would have wanted to play
that
for harry krishna i'm gonna have to
disagree i say white just because i
think there's more long-term margin for
error for for white even if you lose the
pawn in the middle of the board uh at
least you can maybe bail out into an end
game and blacks double pawns there might
become weak or they won't really count
too much if it's just for example a rook
in game or just
maybe a bishop end game but yeah
then again uh yeah you could definitely
make arguments for both sides and that's
why this position is so tense actually
it's rich and full of life i saw like a
huge danger just now and okay it's a
little bit of a pipe dream at the minute
but
if white could white might be able to
lock the black bishop out of the game
so this this would definitely be an
endgame thing it would not be for now
but you know just imagine you know you
managed to get your pawn to g3 and f4
you get nice chain and then that's it
the the bishop on g7
just to show an idea just making some
moves but this pawn structure uh for
example now if white can arrange this
then this bishop is as you mentioned
you're just completely dead uh i mean
it's just staring at this wall of bones
and the only way to ever get it out is
to sacrifice pawns or maybe even
sacrifice his bishop against a pawn
later on but uh yeah that's the dream
long term imagine if we see this later
in the game of anchor this wall of pawns
looking out a piece that would be
seriously bad news for pragnando if we
saw this and like you said yesterday
ivanka we like our pawns in chains
that is not my finest moment
but the thing is that that's what i
remember now
i remember now i want my pawns and
chains we want to
lock them up together
and those pawns they've locked up this
bishop as well
yeah that is the goal long term for
white meanwhile obviously uh pregnant
won't allow this to happen so easily
instead of retreating as queen as i
showed just uh as an example in that
variation he's brought his rook forward
and his idea is to double up his rook
potentially on an open line these two
black rooks
but hare krishna he's got ambitious
intentions himself and he brings his
queen to the side of the board i'm not
sure the queen necessarily wants to
attack on this flank i think maybe her
idea is to zoom the whole way across the
board and start going for pawns or maybe
even start going for the black king
later on um this white queen is really
versatile really flexible she can switch
from side to side if she wants and i
like this last move he's at least
hinting
to prague that he is going on the attack
if you imagine if white gets a couple of
moves again the queen might come across
and now harry the h-born will act as a
battering ram to just remove the shelter
in front of the black king and wow okay
oh my goodness me i mean i did mention
it as an idea but i had never dreamt
that it would happen right now rook
takes knight giving up a rook for a
night in order to ruin the black the
white king's pawn structure and it's
also about this bishop this bishop is
finally let out again it breaks out of
its chains and captures this pawn so
who's got the worst pawn structure here
i have no idea these pawns are ugly this
pawn is isolated but black also has
shattered pawns and does it feel like
enough i'm not so sure because it's all
about rooks as well and with this rook
move harry krishna trying to eliminate
the remaining black rook unless black
whips up an attack long term i think uh
white's advantage of rook versus knight
is going to pay off in the end game
hare krishna very calm but prague we
have to give him credit for playing so
ambitiously
and uh making that sacrifice but uh yeah
no i'm just trying to calculate the
situation here because suddenly there's
a few things that are up for grabs and
i'm looking at that pawn
and i'm thinking can black and he's done
it i've done it he's great he's gone
greedy and then the whole situation is
is rook takes rook uh going to be on the
board and can you ignore that rook or
you can you don't need just ignore this
rook maybe even capture the bishop yeah
possible okay we'll find out we'll find
out this one is really heating up
there's captures on every move there's
threats on every move okay black did
actually capture this rook back and now
white has to make a big decision do you
move this bishop that's under attack or
do you try and be a bit flashy for
example capture this pawn hoping that
maybe next move you can sneak in and
capture this pawn with a nasty check
so many texting options here and uh this
game still in the balance white is
material up but prague is trying to
attack if he can break through and
somehow flick his queen over to the
other side of the board near the white
king suddenly the game could turn so
okay let's go back to the players this
one is chaotic it's wild and this is
what we love to see
uh countrymen these two indian players
but they're showing no respect to each
other really both trying to win this
game
yeah we take spawning vancouver just
move this white bishop
um
not sure that's a pawn worth grabbing
and the reason i'm saying that is
because um yes you grab that pawn
wonderful obviously black can't actually
play queen takes bishop because uh some
material will drop with check
but black can actually start using his
king as a defender and just kind of
solidify those double pawns in the
middle of the board and then the white
queen actually wants to be back in her
ideal
row
there she can flip between the two sides
keep her king under cover she can also
potentially attack some weak pawns on
the left side
yeah so the square you're thinking about
for the black king is the f7 square
actually there it's super safe the black
king is kind of wrapped in cotton wool
by all of its pawns so
really nice defensive idea and uh i
think you're right here
my first instinct is greed greed is good
white's queen can take a couple of pawns
but maybe you shouldn't maybe the threat
is stronger than the execution as they
say keeping that idea in your mind for
later is more important so white's
bishop it does move wow and harry
krishna is he going for checkmate look
at that bishop it's kind of cutting
across the black king it's keeping an
eye on the dark squares near black's
king if white's queen can now i talked
about the black queen picking herself up
and putting herself on the king's side
if white's queen could just put herself
on the f8 square
that's checkmate so okay
i'm i'm shocked the computer says 0.0
but it's wild this position and a draw
is far far away from either player's
mind
i think this one might be decided by a
mistake under time pressure because it
is that
balanced it is that crazy right now and
okay where to put the black queen it
feels like you need to put her somewhere
the black bishop might look too good you
don't really want to move them yeah
the one the one thing that i would say
definitely do not do if you were playing
with the black pieces and that is try to
trade off queens because no
a queenless ending is not going to be
your friend here because the white's
rook is going to be so good instead keep
the queens on and
look for ways to make the white king
uncomfortable
unfortunately it's not that easy to put
her on a square where she can be a
nuisance yeah the black queen's on the
wrong side of the board in a way and uh
at the moment she's kind of happy where
she is because she stops the white rook
from zooming across and trying to use
some open lines to break through to the
black king potentially um okay prague
very nice move i think there it's the
move you highlighted or the idea that
you highlighted at least that black king
guard some pawns but the black pawns
also guard the black king
so just a bit of teamwork there and uh
white has the decision to make the white
rook struggling to find any squares to
use um the white queen
she can take a couple of pawns
but that costs a bit of time that loses
a bit of control
uh okay wow i think i would pick up that
white queen again but the question is
where so much choice for hare krishna
i'm tempted to grab a pawn now which
pawn would you grab here ivanka the ace
seven pawn or the c6 pawn your support
for choice i'm spoiled for choice and i
think i might grab the a7 form because
uh you know the bishop planted itself
there on the h6 square primarily eyeing
the f8 square which is conveniently
located next to the black king so i'm
just thinking hey maybe the queen and
bishop can kind of work together and
threaten checkmate which is not that
easy to defend against and i think we
have to show this because prague i think
he's got the sneakiest idea i've seen in
ages after this move so queen takes pawn
looks like a free pawn and as you
mentioned the queen wants to come behind
and deliver checkmate to the black king
but
well actually i've just noticed a second
sneaky idea one could be to drop the
bishop the whole way back and uh where
does this queen go now she wants to
break through as mentioned on the eighth
rank but this is blocked off to her um
the bishop defending uh defended by the
black queen and if the queen retreats uh
for example if she goes to the wrong
square just a bad square then suddenly
the black queen comes back and suddenly
it's not white delivering checkmate it's
black trying to deliver chatmate on this
diagonal using the queen and bishop to
break through to suddenly the white king
this time
okay centralized instead harry krishna
didn't want to sideline his queen put
her offside by grabbing a pawn on this
square the queen would have been badly
placed so he centralizes her instead a
very solid move and prague reacts
instantly
wow he's so brave using his instincts
there prague he's putting pressure on
this pawn using the queen using the
bishop just making sure that the white
rook cannot move the white rook now
stuck as a defender of the pawn in front
of it and suddenly no checks it looks
like the black king is really vulnerable
but no way to check it with the white
queen because every checking square is
covered by black's pawns or black's
knight yeah
and suddenly i do feel that it's uh
harry krishna who is in big danger
because like you pointed out white rook
tied down and it's probably going to be
all about black's past born sitting on
the sixth row
can march forward if black gets timed
this pawn could potentially be really
dangerous but harry krishna surprising
me again this bishop looks so good such
an attacking piece he's brought it back
to its starting square to attack and
dislodge the black queen the black queen
has to stay in touch with her bishop
they have to defend each other and uh
okay still really really tense as you
mentioned you bank at this point could
potentially decide the game if it
matches down the board but then again at
least now there's less pressure on the
weak f2 point the black queen now forced
onto a different line so maybe it's time
for white to start thinking about
throwing this ball up the board
confusing things maybe ideally you want
to get this rook into the game at some
point not sure how if you move it across
attacking the bishop the bishop can just
be backed up by a pawn defended by a
pawn
it's uh yeah definitely harry krishna
he's having to be more creative suddenly
to create some action uh because black's
moves are just really obvious and uh
this pawn push is coming maybe black can
push some horns here what is white doing
white is a bit stuck
let's go back to the players because
under three minutes now before harry
krishna and you can tell on his body
language he's
unsure he's not so happy he plays the
move i mentioned attacking the black
bishop with his rook that black bishop
would just be defended it would just be
defended by pawn and
once again the dilemma is there white
has to do something otherwise that black
pawn will just continue marching
what really has to
shake black's defenses up a little bit i
have to say i really liked your h for
push harry advancing harry never a bad
idea according to simon our good friend
i think we've both been sitting next to
simon too long now every position we
just want to pick up white's h pawn and
throw it up the board uh here it makes a
lot of sense because black's king
doesn't have too many defenders around
it it only has pawns so if you throw
harry up the board
you could potentially just create some
open lines there but uh okay either way
hari krishna attacking the black bishop
why is prague thinking here yeah going
down to two minutes pregnant i hear he
makes this move
okay this one makes a lot of sense as
well i was advocating pushing the black
sea pawn the black past born forward but
now at least this pawn also guards the
bishop
okay yeah time trouble is going to
decide this game what an interesting
game and what an interesting round this
looks like the bar has been over to
navarro's side all the game against
magnus carlsen is he winning against the
world champion richard report the bar
all the way over to his side against the
world number three daingli ran
duda looking good for him against jordan
from forest and also for gawain jones to
bar over to his side against joo and jun
all right moves yeah moves and hare
krishna he's making his move uh he's
trying to go uh towards the black king
he's just trying to open things up for
the white rook for the white queen and
uh with this pawn push he's just hoping
uh that he can get rid of black central
pawn which is needed as a defender of
the black bishop and
we talked about queen swinging across
towards the enemy kings he has done it
there's a huge huge threat in the
position black's queen if she can just
side step back on the diagonal to the g4
square she will check white's king from
the front and also hit the white rook in
the center of the board so harry krishna
needs to defend against that
he needs to maybe play pawn takes pawn i
was going to say well
what's the solution after pawn takes
pawn i think he wants to recapture that
with his bishop and uh
this one is becoming really tactical
he's trying to deflect away the white
queen from the center of the board so
the black queen can start delivering
some checks and okay we have seen pawn
takes pawn now the black bishop is under
fire so i think it has to move and i
think it can safely take this pawn
wow the evaluation bar no
not liking
harry christian's decision but this is
where human error comes in neither
player is going to play perfect chess
now harry krishna looks more nervous of
the two players if we look on the camera
he's the one gesturing prague looks very
focused and okay the move i mentioned
now queen takes bishop would be a huge
blunder that is not a free bishop it's
poisoned because the black queen would
sidestep back that g4 square we
mentioned with a check and a double
attack winning the white rook so what
else to do
okay
harry krishna needs to move fast
two minutes not easy i mean
it's i don't see a way to defend the
pawn on h2 other than him back with the
queen maybe this is the best move queen
go passive use the queen as a defender
safest move and now prague can actually
grab this pawn anyway with his bishop if
he wants to uh there's still a trap in
the air i think we have to show this
because it's so tactical it's so uh wild
right now let's keep an eye on the
players as well there we go so right now
there was a trap queen takes bishop as
mentioned would have fallen foul of a
double attack a check and this check and
actually that tactic has arisen in the
game not in this way but instead white
dropping back with the queen trying to
defend everything prague said okay take
my bishop please sacrificing it for a
pawn but now again taking the bishop
with the queen would result in a fatal
fork a double attack
so that hasn't happened here the white
king had to move out of the way the
queen has to stay where she is
challenging the black queen and after
the queen retreats rook has stepped up
if we do a quick count black has three
pawns now and a knight black has these
three pawns and a knight just for one
rook
it feels like an advantage for black but
then again both kings are not safe and
uh while the queens remain on the board
harry krishna is potentially
struggling but has some chance for a
counter-attack i think black's bishop
now just needs to retreat uh it just
needs to get to a safe square before it
gets trapped uh so maybe bring it back
here that's the first move i would look
at
and at least just defend everything for
black yeah and i love that bishop
retreat because also it's moving as you
pointed out to a protected square
especially when you're on time trouble
franklander only has uh just under a
minute on his clock so
safety is good yeah i'm not sure who the
queen trade would favor here if the
queens disappear from the board black
has so many pawns okay he does find this
move and uh prague is great actually at
controlling games i've noticed um he
doesn't take too many risks he loves to
put his pieces on protected squares like
this and the rook can give a check for
example but black's king can just step
back and hide the king's super safe now
behind its wall of pawns
it looks one-sided it looks like prague
is
turning things in his favor slowly the
only thing that might stop him is the
clock so yeah let's go back to the
places
any predictions i think predictions are
off in this game
yeah i i think pregnant is going to win
actually
i i think
white's king is unsafe the rook white's
rook isn't particularly effective in
this particular position
and uh the bishop and the knight are
just going to be superb that black
knight is rock-solid supported by porn
this is what we talk about when we say
outposts right yeah this knight is on a
glorious outpost um it's just got its
tentacles out there controlling all
these eight squares
this octo knight and
how i don't see a move really
to make things productive for white at
least and keeping the black king super
safe tucked away
and yeah really instructive i think
you're right as well your banker even if
white can hold this with best play
in practical terms when you've only got
a minute on the clock it's going to be
extremely difficult yeah white's bishop
as well just nothing to do really
it has nothing to look at i mean not
protected it's certainly a bystander
here i mean the only thing that i can
see is that okay well pragnando is
actually doesn't have a plan either he's
just kind of retreated with his king
maybe this is an invitation for the
white queen to take a step forward two
steps forward yeah
and threaten some checks yeah to go to
the e6 square i guess that would lose a
bit of control black would suddenly get
some checks so you have to really
calculate that one but okay hare krishna
just bringing his bishop forward to a
safe square at least now the rook
guarding the white bishop
remember loose pieces drop off so that
bishop no longer loose but pragnanda he
moved instantly yeah that white uh that
king now on a white square a light
square yeah pretty safe he's kind of
priming the position for an end game you
know he's centralizing the king king is
right getting ready for action and uh
now offering a queen trade i think i
might be tempted just to capture it
especially now that the black king is
right in the middle of the board it's
there ready to help out his potentially
weak pawns yeah so he has rejected a
queen trade once pregnant but
in this situation you mentioned ivanka
yeah you can trade off he does that and
now black has passports on both sides of
the board black has pawns
on this flank the h pawn is a passport
and also the c pawn that has pawns on
both sides it's going to be hard to stop
them both yeah and also the white rook
got no squares i mean okay so he moves
up to the eighth row okay so nice row
for the rook to explore you can go to
the left you can go to the right
yeah black has to keep everything
guarded you can do that with your bishop
you can do that with your king and
knight you can protect all your pawns
okay he steps back with the bishop that
bishop is just going to park itself
maybe one square further on the b6
square just to guard pawns
um
suddenly
i mean i advocated the queen trade as
well i thought that was maybe the most
natural the safest move but possibly the
white king was weaker than the black
king just a few moves ago and with that
logic maybe keeping the queens on would
have
at least for a few moves would have
maximized the winning chances suddenly
white's rook does have threats of going
to the corner and trying to gobble up
black's h pawn
suddenly some hint at counter play for
harry krishna and also
he's an in-game
pro yeah whenever i play him i try to
avoid the end game if i can
but one thing that you kind of your
observation about pragnando was all
about like how he likes to keep control
and there you can see with his move he
actually centralized his bishop so that
the bishop can kind of control the
critical squares and at the same time
get ready to defend either porn i'm
thinking about alice and harry on the a
h line yeah that's some really nice
bishop in the middle of the board now
for black guarding everything and
guarding all the squares the white rook
wants to use and
yeah just as i mentioned end games and
hare krishna i said i tried to avoid
them at all costs but then i realized i
did play a 236 move game against harry
krishna so the one end game i've had a
couple of end games against him i had
one the year before that as well it was
a record one
yeah almost a record one yeah the year
before that i think i played 90
something moves against him so um yeah
that's how much i love endgames that's
how much he loves them games and okay
well the players have actually repeated
the position a few times
do you think we'll see a three-time
repetition
because uh the clock is ticking for
pragnanda it's 15 seconds
he's going down almost 10. he's up on
material though he's got an extra pawn
can he keep it yeah black having this
knight and three pawns against the black
mouth seconds three seconds okay they've
repeated the position three times it's a
draw
anti-climax after such an exciting game
but
hard fought game there by both players
both of them shaking their head that was
such an intense game between the two
indians it ends with a draw